DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH FOR FULL
RECORD AFTER A BOMBSHELL REPORT
REVEALS THE STATE UNDERCOUNTER
NURSING HOME DEATHS BY 50% IS 9
OF GOVERNOR CUOMO’S TOP HEALTH
OFFICIALS QUIT.
JOINING ME, CAROL MARKOWITZ.
WHAT POSSIBLE REASON COULD
DEMOCRATS HAVE FOR BLOCKING THE
SUBPOENA?
>> IT IS POLITICS.
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS LONG BEEN
KNOWN IS A TRULY.
IT IS HARD TO OVERLOOK HE STILL
ENJOYS QUITE A GOOD APPROVAL
RATING.
’S ARE NOT POLITICIANS WHO TAKE
CHANCES OR SPEAK MY MIND WILL GO
OUT ON A LIMB TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
THEY ARE PART OF A POLITICAL
SYSTEM AND WILL STAY THAT WAY.
TODD: THERE IS ONE DEMOCRAT WHO
APPEARS TO HAVE GONE OUT ON A
LIMB AND THAT IS LETITIA JAMES
IN NEW YORK, SHE.
THIS OPEN.
WILL SHE SUBPOENA THESE RECORDS?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE.
I’M PROUD OF WHAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL JAMES DID.
ANYONE WATCHING THIS PROGRAM
KNEW THE STORY ALREADY, TALKING
ABOUT THE NUMBERS AND HOW THEY
WERE OBVIOUSLY FLAWED BECAUSE
THEY WERE ONLY COUNTING NURSING
HOME DEATHS THAT HAPPENED IN
NURSING HOMES, NURSING HOME
PATIENTS TAKEN TO HOSPITAL
WASN’T COUNTED, DIED ON THE WAY
TO THE HOSPITAL WASN’T COUNTED
SO WE KNEW FOR SO LONG THIS WAS
FLAWED.
HER INVESTIGATION PUTS THE STORY
FRONT AND CENTER, THIS IS WELL
KNOWN ALREADY AND NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP.
TODD: THE MIDST OF THE MEDIA
DIDN’T REPORT AND INSTEAD
PRAISING GOVERNOR CUOMO AND HIS
ANY WINNING PRESS CONFERENCES
INCLUDING THIS LITTLE DITTY WE
DUG UP FROM THE ARCHIVES,
TWEETING THIS FROM THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH LAST YEAR, QUOTE, PEOPLE
WILL WATCH THE NEW YORK GOVERNOR
CUOMO PRESSER WHEN THEY STUDY
CRISIS LEADERSHIP ESPECIALLY HIS
REMARK ABOUT MISINFORMATION
BEING MORE DANGEROUS THAN THE
VIRUS.
DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA WILL HOLD
HIM ACCOUNTABLE?
>> THEY SEEM LIKE THEY MIGHT
START BUT I DON’T HAVE A LOT OF
FAITH.
HIS BROTHER WAS INTERVIEWED
THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS, HE
LAUNCHED HIS BOOK ON LEADERSHIP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC
AND I DON’T SEE A GIANT SHIFT IN
THE WAY THE MEDIA TREATS HIM.
THERE WILL BE LIPSERVICE BUT I
DON’T SEE GIANT CHANGE ON THIS.
TODD: THE PANDEMIC KILLED SO
MANY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE A NEW OP-ED CALLED THE
FUTURE IS FLORIDA.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> FLORIDA IS OPENING THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC AND HAVE BEEN DOING
GREAT.
IT HAS GONE BACK LEADERSHIP.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS DECIDED
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS SHOULD BE
OPEN AND THEY HAVE BEEN AND
THEIR NUMBERS MIRROR NEW YORK
AND CALIFORNIA’S NUMBERS WHO ARE
TIGHTLY CLOSED.
POLITICIANS WHO HAVE A BACKBONE,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS DIDN’T WANT TO
SEE BUSINESSES IN RUINS AND IT
IS NOT JUST BUSINESS POLITICS
BUT PEOPLE POLICIES.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING OTHER
GOVERNORS STUDY AND LOOK INTO.
TODD: PEOPLE OUR AGE SAY MAKE A
BREAK FOR IT BECAUSE WE ARE THE